should we start
all right
welcome everyone this is the famous
after lunch session just so you know but
no luckily for you this is gonna be a
really relaxed and easygoing session so
you can take it easy actually no not at
all
this is a no ha actually kind of
technical session we're not some
information and you know it after all
it's about get so I hope you guys have
had your coffee and you have habit ready
to go so let's get started
my name is Luca yo-yo I work as a
freelance programmer this is me
freelancing from home so I'm a
programmer by other I also do a lot of
training but the training I don't do
from home I actually travel to the
places we are not here to talk about
that dough nor the fact that I wanna set
here we are here to talk about meat so
how many of you are using it today ok so
all of you that's good
do you think that get is hard no how
many of you think it is hard ok so I
guess the other half think that is easy
or medium well I for one once thought it
was hard
well complicated and I was wondering why
so I don't know if you have a Google for
why it is hard but I did and you know
you get a bunch of different kinds of
results who are you know people complain
with a sale you know I hate get it is
complicated and various degrees of
frustration but at some point you see
yeah it is a nightmare
but then why is good good
so I mean someone is now thinking about
the fact that get my
good so I became curious and I thought
to myself let's investigate this
so the question went from being like why
is it hard to what is get and so began
my journey to understand what it is so
this session is what I've learned during
this journey of really understanding
what get is and what came after it when
when you come out the other side of this
journey hopefully you will have a
different relationship to get so you
know the first thing you do when you
research something you find the xkcd
comic for it and this is the one forget
so you know this is get and it's a tool
to collaborate through a beautiful
distributed graph theory three model ok
so how do you use it no idea you just
memorize this command and if everything
goes bad you delete everything and start
over yeah not really the answer I was
looking for however if you look at this
you know there are some kernels of truth
here so beautiful distributed graph
theory three model is it is it just a
joke or is there something real there so
next step was of course Wikipedia and my
question was what is a tree and I was
like mmm not really that but eventually
I found you know that that's another
tree I was looking for this is the tree
I'm looking for and three what is it
rhythm a tree is an undirected graph of
nodes that are interconnected by exactly
one person okay we have something known
you have a base conceptual base two to
start from okay
now have you ever run the command git
log I guess you've done done it's in
some way or another what comes out of
gate log neat log looks a lot like this
where every one of those boxes is a
commit those commits they are connected
and at the end of the one of these lines
the latest commit in a line has a branch
name do you recognize this yeah
now of course you can have different
branches now let's look at this and can
we say that this is a graph yeah we can
see this is a graph it's a bunch of
notes with interconnected so so that's a
graph but let's look at how many ways
there are to go from one node to a node
to the other so from that node to this
how many paths are there one yeah what
about from this to this how many ways
are there to go from one to the other
still one so yes this is a graph where
every node is interconnected by exactly
one path right just like in the xkcd
comic cell so yeah this is indeed a tree
but now let's take a look at this node
the definition of tree was that it was
an undirected graph which means you can
go either way but in it we know that
every node every commit just knows about
its parent a commit doesn't know how
many commits come after it they just
know what the parent is so this is not
an undirected tree this is a directed
tree now let's consider something else
what if you merge those two branches now
this is the plot twist now remember my
question before how many paths are there
between nodes let's try it again
let's go from here to here how many ways
are there
- yeah no longer one so this is
officially not longer at three and
that's why the xkcd comic said then it
was a graph in the graph theory it was a
three model it was not really a tree so
this is a directed graph now let's take
a look at this node you can see that
there there are no circular reference
you cannot go back there is exactly one
there is one way you can't go either
direction so this is not so this is a
directed graph not only that but it is
also a directed acyclic graph
because it doesn't have any recursive
reference and this is exactly the object
model that that is the foundation of get
it is a directed acyclic graph where
every node is a commit in your history
and of course if you know look around in
the internet you usually find this
shortened to dag or to better remember
it you can say dag now let's look at
this again a let's unpack one of those
nodes which is a commit right so let's
look at the object model inside one of
those commits so you ever commit now
what's inside a commit I'll tell you
inside a commit is something called a
tree again but the tree is just a good
way of representing a directory and
inside the directory there are files and
those files are called blobs now as we
said before a commit as a reference to
its parent which has the exact same kind
of graph underneath and at the end of
course you have the branch reference now
this is basically everything there is to
get get
is a graph a directed acyclic graph
where every node consists of trees and
blobs so you see that it's actually
pretty simple
of course you dosed those objects you
recognize them probably with as those
values have you seen those values when
you get it either through a GUI or to
the command line
have you wondered what those are those
long strings those strings are the
result of when you run a hash algorithm
on those objects most more precisely the
sha-1 hash algorithm or if you are into
the you know the in the gate community
we say the sha you don't say sha-1 so
the shells are the IDs
the unique IDs for each one of those
objects so a commit as a char and a tree
has one and the blob has one so we said
that this hash is calculated by running
the hash algorithm on the object
contents so that's easy to say because
if you run it on a file of course you're
gonna get a hash of the files contents
so that's easy
what about a tree a directory how do you
run a hash algorithm on a directory well
you run it on the directories path what
about a commit which is an objective in
earth itself what does a commit contain
that you can possibly run a hash
algorithm on so that is what we are
going to find out we are going to take a
look behind the scenes and because I see
some faces whether they skeptical they
say I don't believe you this is not how
it is it's too simple ridiculously
simple so what we are going to do
together is we are going to create a
commit but not like the way you usually
do it we are going to create a commit by
constructing this graph from the blob to
the tree to the commit to
the branch from the bottom up in order
to do that well I'm gonna use some
commands that you probably never heard
of and that you after today will
probably never see again because those
commands are the low-level commands
those are called plumbing commands that
every if you have a gate installation
you have those commands but those are
they directly manipulate that graph so
you don't normally don't use them
because other commands have been built
on top of them to be more user friendly
can you believe it the high level
commands are there to be user friendly
so imagine what how these are but but
these are the basic commands the word
are from the start when they install
what not the developed gate he didn't
write the the commands that you use
every day he wrote these ones and then
he left it because he was happy with it
and then direct community took over the
project and built let's make it more
user friendly yeah all right so we have
what we have here is a command prompt
that's pointing to a directory which you
see here and this is our sample project
is a directory called SRC and it
contains a calculator let's look at that
calculator it's an embarrassing C
program that it's not even a calculator
it just tells you there it is but it
doesn't really matter this is what we
are going to commit using the plumbing
command and as a reference
I put the graph that you saw before well
we'll keep it as a reference you know in
the bottom part of the screen okay now
this is not even a git repository at all
so let's start by running the famous git
init command which transforms this
regular directory into a git repository
now that's what will happen on the right
and UT rectory appears code get have you
doing
you know about gif directory have you
ever looked inside yeah alright if you
have then you probably know words what's
there
if you don't I'll show you here is
they're actually called objects now we
have been talking about an object model
so it stands to reason that all those
trees and blobs and commits they're
going to be stored there and right now
there are just two directories and those
are empty
what about branches we usually hear that
the branch is just a reference to a
commit well there is a graphical drafts
so that's probably where they go
refs heads empty empty everything is
empty here and indeed if you run git log
it's not I'll you don't have any commits
yet ok so let's start by committing this
calculator file now I also told you that
everything is hashed right so the first
thing you do if you want to commit a
file you need to ask get a get round
your sha-1 hash algorithm on this file
so that we can get an ID back and the
command is called hash object and of
course then you give it to the path to
the file and it gives you this famous
sha back but did you notice that nothing
happened here that's because git is
being developed by programmers and of
course if you just ask it for a hash it
will give you exactly that it won't
actually store the file anywhere if you
also want to store it then of course you
need to say hash object - W which stands
for right and now we have a new
directory could be 5 which you recognize
are the two first letters in the hash
now what's inside this directory it's a
file that is named after the rest of the
shell now stands to reason that we
should be able
to look at the contents of the file
right it should be our file do you agree
on that so if we just try to read the
contents of that file what do we see
garbage so turns out that when you ask
get to store your files it is going to
zip them because you know text
compresses really well so in order to
look at the contents of the file you
need to use another plumbing command
which is called capped file doesn't have
any to to to with cats then you say
print and then you give it the D hash
which I forgot to copy my clipboard so
let's hash it again because it does our
current kind of hard to type so CAD file
P and indeed we get back our file so
yeah if you notice this one is 138 bytes
and the original was was 160 so we are
indeed it compressed okay so now we have
a blob next step is to have a tree which
represents the directory SRC right now
would you expect that there is something
called create tree something like that
well there is but you you can't invoke
it on a directory because what we've
done here so far is that we have told it
save this file in your object object
database but it is not going to keep
track of it if we make if you make a
change to the original file it is going
to completely ignore it because we
haven't told it to track the file and
how does it know which file which files
is it should track well it keeps a list
of paths of all the files that you
should track and that list
once is called exactly what you expect
it's an index it's an index on with it's
a registry of files that you should keep
track of every word about the index yeah
when you say get add you are adding a
file to the index and you are telling it
please get keep track of this file for
me so the low level command to add
something to the index is update index -
- add now one might wonder why isn't
there a add index I don't know but there
is an update index - - add alright next
thing you need to say is okay is this a
read write text file or is this a script
and the way you tell gif that this is a
text file that you can read and write is
of course by passing this number this is
the UNIX way of expressing readwrite
Flags on files next step is to pass the
hash of the blob because we are adding a
blob and we are telling it to track it
so we need to tell it also the path on
the working directory new file appears
called index let's take a look at the
contents of that file what we would
expect to see more garbage well it turns
out that in so imagine that in that file
there is an entry for every file in your
project now think about your biggest
project how many files are there in
think of that number there's gonna be a
line in that file for each one of them
so of course one does not simply store
such large lists in a text file you
store it in some kind of binary format
which is what the index is but of course
you can look at it by using another
plumbing command
called LS files and then you say stage
because you want to see all the
information and what you get back is
exactly one line you recognize this is
the it's our blob this is the fact that
it's a read/write text file here is the
path and what is this
well this session is only an hour so if
you want to know what that number is you
just find me afterwards I'll be around
and I'll show you exactly what the
number is for now you just have to
wonder so now we have added an ended and
answer to the index next step is so get
has all the information it needs now to
create a tree it knows the blob the idea
of the blob the SHA it knows the path
that it points to so now we can you know
parse that path and create a tree for
every directory so now we can say get
right tree and now we get two more of
these and you might wonder why - isn't
there just one directory yeah I wonder
that too
so let's print the contents of that tree
Oh
it contains another tree let's take a
look at a dead tree cut file - P and
there you have our blob so now you see
that get creates a tree for the root of
your project and then it creates that
another tree to represent the SSRC
directly and under that tree you have
your calculator blob okay so you can you
can basically see their directory
structure okay so now we have blob one
blob two trees we now we need to create
a commit so we are approaching the
answer to the question what is a commit
them so let's copy the hash of the
route 3 and now let's invoke commit 3
pass the hash of the tree of the root
directory and now you can also pass a
not multiple trees just one tree then
you pass the message add the calculator
calculator and we get back another hash
which of course is saved inside here as
well
it's 141 bytes what could possibly be in
that object let's take a look
it's metadata it's information about the
commit it doesn't have anything to do
with the files that it contains however
you see that a commit has a reference to
the root tree and of course you see you
know that from there you can recursively
list the content until you reach the
blobs so that's one field another field
is the name of the author and the email
address and then you have this number
you know where it is almost that is what
it's called is usually called the UNIX
epoch that's a timestamp and why is it
expressing as as that number well you
can of course convert it to another
format so what is that number that
number is the number of seconds that
have passed since January 1st 1970 yeah
and that's how you store a date in a
UNIX system you store it as that number
now let me open up brief parentheses
here so you guys are programmers right
now if you are if your task is to store
this number what data type would you two
you have to store it in a database
forever which which which data type will
you choose for that number long yeah int
yeah well let's des take int interest
probably the default in many programming
languages and int is what is int
actually it's a signed 32-bit integer
right now this number is the number of
seconds that are passing so this number
is increasing it's a red increasing I'll
show you and it's never gonna stop
increasing so at some point regardless
of what data type you choose you're
gonna reach the end of the possible
numbers you can represent with the data
type now it turns out that if you store
it as a signed 32-bit integer you're
gonna run out of space at some point and
that point in the future is not that far
it's January 19 2013 8 so 18 years from
now at 3 I am 353 1407 a.m. on January
19 2013 8 we are gonna overflow the int
and you know what happens done because
it's assigned its assigned datatype it's
gonna wrap around and go back to -
exactly the other end of the spectrum
which you can also convert into a date
and that date is December 13 19 or 1 so
this is called the UNIX 2038 problem now
if you think about the UNIX of course
Linux is a UNIX operating system do you
have an Android phone yeah
that contains dates in this format also
if EV iOS it's also based on on UNIX
think about all the databases that
exists in the world
Postgres they all store dates in this in
this for my sequel turns out that if you
have an old enough Android phone you can
try to set date to this January 19 2013
8 and Android will crash and the phone
won't boot again yeah so that's kind of
interesting so but of course I know we
found out about this problem around 2006
it was actually a chat program by AOL
would discover this problem so the a
transition has started so new versions
of these operating systems days are
storing it as a 64-bit still signed
integer but that gives us more no Liam
so now we are the limit is going to be
something around here 2 billion so it's
a problem for future generations so
modern systems they store it a 64 bit
but older systems still have this
problem but let's not worry about a
nominee we still have 19 years to go so
brief parenthesis there let's look at
this again now you might wonder why are
there two fields one author and one
committed those are usually the same for
most projects remember that it was
created to store the history of the
Linux kernel and in the Linux kernel
since it's so critical to many systems
you can you cannot simply you know
submit I commit commit code to that not
even close actually
you can submit your code and then it's
gonna go through a review process well
many people are gonna have to look at it
and sign off that yes we can integrate
this code into the kernel so in the end
you will have one person who is the
author of the change and you have a not
will have another person who is the one
that signed off last and said yes I am
responsible for this code being
integrated in the Linux kernel and
that's the committer
and you want to keep track of both those
so that's why it's two different fields
and then of course you have the message
so this is what what a commit is and
this hash is the result of running the
sha-1 algorithm on top of all these
fields alright so now let's do you think
this isn't is is this interesting at all
is it exciting maybe not I'll show you
something that's even more exciting now
we're going to create a committee using
the regular commands the ones that
you're using everyday so because we need
to commit so let's just yeah by the way
nobody told me let's run git log still
don't have a commit what did we forget
to do the branch we still haven't
created a branch if we close this
remember that the brands are just
references pointing to commit stay this
heads directory still empty let's hope
that I have the no I don't let me see
there you go this is hopefully the right
one so do I stop it
do I have it in the clipboard let me
just copy that by using the menu yes is
it yes perfect okay so how do you create
a branch done well you use another new
level command called update ref like
update index you give it what commit
through this branch point to this one
and first let me say where should it be
created should be creating into wrath
heads master and then you give it the
hash of the commit oh the other way
around
it update ref this laughs heads master
that was not the right one right that
was not the right okay so let's take a
look at well you know what I think I
still have it here
now which one of those was it now I'm
gonna use these two right here forgot to
call oh yes there you go let's not lose
those hashes because otherwise I need to
delete everything and start over
update ref refs heads master that was
the right one at least get told me a
this is not a this is not a commit you
cannot point a branch to a tree or a
blob you need to point it to a commit so
now let's run git log as indeed we now
have history okay so now let's create a
commit using the regular command so we
have two commits so let me first open up
this calculator file just to make a
change let's make a meaningful change
have you written a comment like that
before I have just to make sure
everybody's on the same page now let's
add dick now now you know what happens
when you say get add right it's gonna
take the file create the hash save the
blob and add it to the index all in one
command git add and then you say git
commit
and to use for comment and now we have
to commit now the latest commit we have
is the one we have just created and this
is the one we created before so now
let's grab this commit ID and let's
print its contents you see a difference
compared to before you still have a tree
but now you have another field which is
the parent and this is the commit hash
that we had before so indeed a commit
keeps whoo exactly one reference to its
parent now of course if you have a merge
commit they're dead that's gonna have
more than one parent so we will have two
lines their parent one point two and I
can tell you this you're probably never
gonna encounter it but a merge commit
can have more than two parts it can have
n number of parents then it's called a
octopus merge I actually never done it
in my life
but I know it exists you basically have
four branches and you merge them all
together into one imagine the merge
conflicts yeah let's not do that so so
now I want to take this tree and I want
to take a look at it so now before we
did bottom up now we do top down we
start from the tree of the latest
committed we did where we added a
comment let's drill down so now this we
this is the root three and we get
another tree let's print the content of
that and now we reach the blob so this
is the new blob right now let's take a
look at that what do you expect to see
if I look at the blob of the file time
modified now I'm a changed one line what
do you expect to see in the blob
the diff
it's the entire file yes so what happens
every time you commit get creates an
entire snapshot of all your files in
your entire working directory all the
files all the trees it's a snapshot of
how things are the moment you commit and
that's where every commit now this is
powerful because if you have ever used
git feature to rewrite history when you
move commits around you change the order
or you squash them together that's
possible because every commit is its own
snapshot it's its own unit so you can
move them around and it doesn't really
matter did that would have been possible
if you'd just recorded the differences
from the previous one because it would
have been impossible to reorder them
which is the main difference between get
and all the other source control
seasonal claim before it all of them
saved just the difference it's called
the Delta while get saves the entire
snapshot which means that if you run
something like git diff and you say show
me the difference between the commits
that came before master you give it a
reference a branch and then you say go
back one parent because you can only go
backwards so that that's our syntax that
means give me the parent of that
reference and of course you can go back
the parent the parent the parent the
part on the parent if there are a lot of
them you can say Goten backwards anyway
give me the difference between the
parent of master and master it's gonna
show you yes indeed you modify that line
but what if you invert them
the diff is going to be the opposite
those diffs are calculated on the fly
because git has all the files every time
in every commit but now I can see some
of you going in ocean shaking their
heads and see yeah
that's why my hard disk is full and
indeed it's kind of wasteful imagine all
the commits just think about the Linux
kernel all the files that are there and
the thousands upon thousands of commits
how much space is gonna take so those
are cool to loose objects and those are
created when you just work with your
repository
every time you committed to loose
objects because those are fast to look
up but at some point gate is gonna say
it's time to tie these things up here so
it's gonna run something called a
garbage collection yes indeed
it has a garbage collector where it is
gonna look for those blobs run a
heuristic algorithm on those files to
determine what what blobs are similar
what blobs are presented the same file
with minor differences and that is gonna
just store the difference okay she's
gonna look at all the blobs find the
same file across multiple blobs then
they tell me what is the first versions
the first version of this file and then
stored the deltas and that's a command
that you never need to run directly but
it's run regularly could get repack and
look what happens in here all those
objects have disappeared and they have
been packed into a so-called POC file
and that file contains just the
differences indeed you can say that
there is exactly one Delta because we
just made one change okay and of course
you can take a look at you can say get a
how many objects do you have right now
zero objects okay but other
in the pack oh I always get those wrong
yes so I have zero loose objects but I
have one part file and that part file
contains exactly eight objects which are
the ones that we created together the
trees the blobs in the commits all right
was that interesting yeah good so let's
take a look done now with all this
information let's take a look at what is
get done given all this get is a
snapshot machine with a domain-specific
language built on top of it and that
domain-specific language are all the
commands that you use to manipulate that
graph we have seen how we used commit
three and write three all those you can
see them as a domain-specific language
to manipulate that kind of graph so git
is actually a Content rocker is not even
a source control system it can track
anything right the dis directed acyclic
graph model isn't specific to tracking
source source files it can track
anything so it's a Content tracker
but if you consider the fact that it
represents files as blobs and direct to
these trees you can say oh by the way
sorry I forgot to mention that if it's a
content tracker it even says it in the
manual it is a stupid content trucker
and why is it stupid because it's really
simple I mean at the core that's all
there is to it so it's a Content tracker
but it's also a file system because it
has abstractions for what are really
files and directories into the code
blobs and trees so it's a virtual file
system and indeed if you look around in
the documentation you see that git is
often
refer to as a virtual file system but
let's not stop here we also saw that
every object in that model has an unique
ID which is the hash the shell so really
it is a hash table just like JavaScript
I really need to ask a programmers yeah
I was hoping for none but so it is a
hash table it's a key/value dictionary J
so let's agree the JSON is a key value
dictionary where every ID points to one
of those three objects so indeed it is
very simple at its core but I know you
might wonder why why would I care about
all this do I have any use for this
information
well what how does have if I have this
mental model of what get really is
because it is basically this how does
that help me on my day to day work well
let me show you a quote first you should
let's all agree that having a clear
history of your source code is a good
thing can we agree on that because it's
a record of how your codebase changed so
that if you keep it you know clear
that's gonna help when you go back and
look at why something has been changed
to know the way it is so let keep your
own a story table however if you ever we
use a source control system you know
that those source control system that
you have used in the past they were
pretty unforgiving once you commit
something that's it you can't go back
and tied tight tied things up afterwards
so how can you keep a history readable
done well the only way is not making any
stakes so or some people do it by just
working things out in their head first
and never make mistakes so that's how
they have a clear history for the rest
of us we can use stuff like git rebase
that is go back and rewrite history
after the fact to remove commits that
don't make sense or squash them together
or change the order so that history
becomes readable but you can are still
free to make mistakes and you know said
this in stores so and you said something
else he said if you can summarize this
in one sentence is don't expose your
crap so you can in us in a way you can
work the way you prefer have your own
workflow commit often commit seldom
doesn't really matter as long as you can
go back afterwards and make it readable
for everyone else including future you
so let me give you an example of what
you can do now this is a sandboxed
environment it's get in a browser but
it's not really good it's an
implementation of git in JavaScript so
it doesn't support every command but the
good thing that it does is that it draws
the graph as you work so if I make a
commit and I could give it a message B
then it's going to show me how that
effects the graph all right so as you
can see we have a master branch I just
made a commit you see that it looks
exactly like the things we'd be looking
at for the past 45 minutes so but if I
have this mental model as I work let's
see what I can do let's see that I'm in
a master branch and I made a commit and
now I'm on a roll so now I'm working and
saying oh let me implement this feature
I'm really getting somewhere you see
let's make D but then a bug report comes
in someone asked me you need to fix a
bug okay but now I have three commits
that are not supposed to go anywhere yet
but I have to fix the bug and the bug
was in the snapshot represented by
commit a so how what do I do now well
let me first create a new branch and you
know how that's created updates ref what
the low-level command but you say git
branch let's create a branch called
experiment that points to the commit
where I'm at right now and now I have a
new reference pointing to that commit
which means I can take the master
reference and move it back to where it
was when I started so when I saw that I
say git reset hard which means I really
mean it
you really need to move this now and you
say where do you want to move it well to
a so you can use the the SHA or you can
say from head or let's say master how
many commits backwards 1 2 3 so on today
and now master is just a reference I
just moved it to point a different
commit now my working directory is
synchronized with that snapshot right
and now I can fix the bug and make a new
commit now I want to resume work on my
experiment
so I synchronize my working directory
with the snapshot that was in experiment
so I check out experiment and all my
files are exactly as they are in that
snapshot however that bug fix will be
really good to have where I'm at right
now so let's
grab that commit or apply the difference
between the snapshot in bug-fix and the
snapshot where I'm at right now by using
a command called cherry-pick which means
take that commit and apply it on top of
where I'm at right now so now that
commit is appears twice because it's not
like I moved it I just took the snapshot
that was there and applied it on top of
mine and created a new commit but now it
looks like the bug fix came after the D
which is actually what happened but I
don't want I don't want that history I
don't want it to look that way
I want to tidy things up so that the
back face came before my experiment how
do I do that well let me just reset
again so that I remove the latest
cherry-picked commit and instead let me
rebase what does every base mean done
this this this branch is based on top of
a right now what I want to do is that I
want to base it on top of bug fix
instead so I change the base of that
commit so that's what rebase means and
look what happens now
so I'm basically took that sequence of
snapshots and moved apparent that once
was a and I move it to become the
bug-fix and now it looks like the bug
fix came first and then my experiment
came afterwards
now all these operations are possible
because gift is a graph of nodes and
every node points to a snapshot so that
is why it's useful to know these things
because you can work the way you prefer
you don't have to adjust yourself to the
tool instead the tool adjusts to you and
at the same time you can have a clean
beautifully clean history now there is
an argument going which is a
philosophical argument you might
encounter on the internet which is why
what do we really want do we want clear
history or do we want true history
because of course as you saw now when I
rebased it looks like bug fix became
before my experiment while in reality
the bug fix came after in time so that's
not what actually happened I tidy up
history to make it look better so if you
think about it too much
there is an argument about so history
indeed is not really reflection of what
happened is what you want it to look
like so are you going back and changing
history to make it better how does that
apply to human history yeah don't think
about it too much what I can say my
point of view is that the history in the
context of source control history is
useful if you can understand it it's not
useful if it's a mess so I prefer to
tidy things up even if it's not a
reflection of what actually happened
because I know how life was when source
control systems where a reflection would
actually happen history was
mess so it's better to have it tidy up
and that's the example I gave you before
so if you are going to remember one
thing from this session I wanted to
remember three things this is the first
one the get is accountant trucker and
nothing more than that
it just happens to be used as a source
control system the second thing is do
not ask what you can do for get instead
ask how what get can do for you I mean
to choose your workflow and when I say
when I say your workflow I mean your
personal workflow when you're working
but also your team's workflow how do you
want to collaborate on this project how
many branches do you want to keep what's
your emergen strategy to choose that
regardless of what's possible don't
think about rebase and cherry-pick and
merge conflict just decide what does
your project need and how does your team
feel comfortable with and then choose
the way you use get to support that
workflow because git doesn't have an
opinion supports everything it's just a
graph and the third thing is to keep a
clean history five minutes to go before
I leave you I have a plus at course out
and with the plus side but there are
also 30 days trial could advance to get
tips and tricks I know
advanced is probably not the first thing
we're going to look up when you learn it
but that course will show you techniques
similar to the ones that I've shown you
here enough to the shameless plug thank
you for your attention